hugo boss plus de champ qui se trouve
sur super ont-ils enfin sorti sur steam
souvenez vous c'est ce jeu on joue avec
le plus la times au ralenti comme ça
c'est bien stylé je suis hors cadre
maintenant alors le but c'est de tuer
des ennemis
finalement et la particularité c'est
qu'on peut arrêter le temps voilà en
fait dès que je bouge le temps marche
normalement et dès que j'arrête de
bouger le temps se tape il tape et
esquive se dégage
voyez up et dès que j'ai aidé que je
bouge où je meurs dès que je bouge au
beurre regardez là ça a marché en léger
recul et hop la tête explose finalement
et là on a un petit récap de cette
action exceptionnelle de la part de
chacun au char vraiment un gros niveau
oui on doit esquiver les balles ce temps
duo est aujourd'hui une balle deux
balles et est et non pas tant mouche a
causé cause et pourrait faire quoi la
rade clic à ok je peux lancer aussi
stylée je peux lancer mon arme sur le
mec pour lui faire mal et lui met une
bonne tête génial aulas et de
l'infiltration est ce qu'on peut
anticiper son mouvement
c'est raté peut-être là oh là là quelle
jolie dit à mon gars parfait tu as y en
avait un la ok allez ça va y aller
la halde est vieille et je te prennent
ce qu'ils avaient en outre l'attendait
plus de balles au nom auger casse en
deux je suis caché qu un g2 marc
esquiver les balles au nom atteint les
tessitures pour de vrai savary
hop là lui meurt ou hop hop je croise
souvent mais je mène la danse dans le
couple tamek c'est génial c'est génial
le style est présent ou le dernier
[Musique]
[ __ ] lé nouveau niveau ils sont ultra
stylée mon garage et l'invention d'un
james bond dans quelques instants ça me
fait très plaisir sans les muscles mais
james bond quand même là
la haye les skis mordant courant au plat
l esquive mais pas trop non plus à gmail
visé [ __ ] j'ai pu d'adamo défrichèrent
ok ok jouglar faire sonner ce bond du
prime à la fois comme lui je le revois
mon arme dessus
c'est l'heure de l'outaouais sont malins
ils prennent les armes mais [ __ ] de
toi tu ramasses palard bâtard non il y
en a un autre à temps plein encore un
[ __ ] maintenant j'ai raté je suis
perdu non mais par delà ce sont des
armes ça fait pas ça y'a plus de
ralentis on s'en bat l'oeil mais c'est
dur pour demeurer [ __ ] je suis en
galère sur un vieux niveau quoi oh là là
on a eu il y en a un autre derrière nous
et bien sûr nous toi ça te choque
on l'a vu c'est bon ça y est [ __ ]
enfin génial et les regarder ce
merveilleux replay bla bla ils le tuent
au point chercham comme un gros con get
over it
il faut sauter route face à face à face
à eux
non il a eu le temps de me mettre une
balle [ __ ] eux ça arrive de là bas
aussi
on l'a vu au lalalalalala ce match qu'il
faut c'est chaud fort heureusement que
j'ai pu j'ai chopé son arme il paraît qu
entre les gens elle est grosse paire de
bas tarifs baissent mais non il va être
promu il est beaucoup trop forts ces
bons aux profondes armes aux jeunes le
mail suivant please l'arbre est au
départ
oh non mais là ce qui se passe mais qu
mais non mais mon gars c'est over style
et c'est incroyable d'en apprendre
larmes oh non j'ai raté non j'ai raté oh
là là là là je n'ai même plus après les
thèmes proches je suis concentré obata l
esquive mais non
c'est pour la balle en plein coeur
olalalala ce level été fantastique mais
qui reconnaît je crois que c'est le jeu
le plus jouissif auquel jouer quoi faut
que justice des armes de mêlée la sapa
en corps à corps mais qu au nord où ils
ont le temps aude a réussi à toucher
toutes les réponses et what you get to
which is c'est génial
bla bla houston up non tu m'auras pas
olala c'était moi le mec ou alors on les
connaît dans des toilettes il faut se
faire lui en live a refusé en poupe et
voilà on contourne et on te défonces qui
d'autre veut ce bail tu la vois pas
gâché une balle pour lui on va lancer le
plus à pont d'oye s'est cassé alors
impossible il ya trop de gens partout
[ __ ] attente attente en hockey est là
tom cruise est avec nous lui il arrive
bla bla blart us patent pour la
bouteille on avance
via le poteau ça nous touche pas on
lance à son retour d'une autre côté aux
sautes ou le défaut ce au profit
d'apoula ya un tri à faire payer pour
tout les tuer d'un coup au regard des
eaux lalalalalalalalala alors la no they
didn't succès début ça apprendra à trop
parler ou les balles me frôlent louga où
on a un mec ce level et du en fait faut
aller vers le bar avec lui ils
réalisèrent le bar on essaie il faut en
fait aux homos bien c'était moi j'étais
trop concentré un grand héros fait
preuve de concentration ta première que
j'ai inventé aulas alors là on l'attend
mais déjà on arrive on arrive c'est déjà
la merde toi ça dégage
nous avons vidé au hockey je t'ai eue
olalalala ok on l'a eue ou à tancer
jamais aussi bon ça mélange un peu
physique et et distant monsters qui se
passe là [ __ ] ça m'arrivait public et
aux camions dans la gueule par là hop
voilà on estime également de justesse ok
attendez je vois des bouteilles là on va
essayer d'aller choper à l'amex et sur
place il ya enfin bon ok ça dégage super
super j'ai craqué ce système ils ont
craqué de système mais non
ok on est beau plein je viens de faire
un coup de folie mon gars qui dégage
what you're gonna do baby when i'm
coming fort qu'ils hissent méchant c'est
trop long comme prato la sallaz et
pertinents on doit le faire voler oh là
là là là j'ai kiffé sa mère au maire
j'ai pu de bâle où ces morts c'est bon
c'est la paille tu peux tu peux ne pas
s'y sont-ils synthèse pour entrer dans
le gign
ok ok j'estime ok ok ils cassent la
remet ça le touche quand même je lui
prends la sienne
et je déteste les enfants après 20
minutes d' analyse très compliqué j'ai
finalement trouvé comment faire il faut
rechercher comme un gros fdpc show la
veille ce qu'on fait j'ai parlé trop
vite on les apps qui s'empilent on les a
tous eu c'était dur comme du alors là
c'est ce style hors norme mais la
technique c'était juste d'aller se
cacher ici sous la gauche subit déjà une
sacré bonne chance sur super nes était
pas là mais ça vous a plu c'est simple
ce soir champêtre vidéo je joue à ce jeu
une fois le montage
voilà c'est faux alors très vite dans
cette prochaine vidéo et on n'en ressort
peut-être sur super intense est-il nerfs
savoir regarder à trouver dans une
prochaine vidéo qui a du monde plus
[Musique]